et en termine avec israël pionnier en
matière de vaccination contre le coc vie
de 19 le pays s'apprête à renoncer ou
pas sanitaires à partir de minuit le
passeport vert ne sera demandé que pour
les évènements et dans les lieux jugés à
hauts risques un allègement des mesures
alors que le variant mikron continue de
se propager elle est précision depuis
tel aviv avec paula slayer journalistes
et internationale le conseil des
ministres israélien a voté en faveur de
nouvelles mesures pour gérer la pandémie
decaux vide qui entreront en application
ce dimanche tout d'abord ils abolissent
le passeport vers le grime passe
obligatoire jusqu'à présent pour accéder
notamment au lieu de loisirs les
non-vaccinés pourront avoir accès aux
restaurants bars hôtels et cinéma un
certificat vaccinale qui ne sera plus
requis que pour l'accès à des espaces
considérés comme à haut risque ce qui
inclut les mariages ou encore les fêtes
il ne sera plus nécessaire de présenter
un test pcr négatif pour la sortie du
territoire mais cela restera obligatoire
pour entrer en israël il n'y aura
d'autre part plus de date d'expiration à
la validité du certificat pour les
personnes ayant reçu une troisième ou
une quatrième doses pour les personnes
n'ayant reçu que deux doses ou les
personnes ayant guéri du coc vide mais
n'étant pas vacciner un nouveau test
sera nécessaire tous les quatre mois
les travailleurs non vaccinés dans les
secteurs de l'éducation de la santé et
de l'assistance sociale devront eux se
faire tester deux fois par semaine ce
sont des recommandations du ministère
israélien de la santé et le premier
ministre naftali bennett a déclaré
qu'elle permettrait au pays de retrouver
une forme de normalité
il est déterminé à alléger les
restrictions en israël mais il a noté
que le pays subissait encore une vague
importante de cadeaux mikron est dit que
les deux à trois prochaines semaines
resterait difficile et que le nombre de
cas sérieux continué à augmenter mais
des signes encourageants montrent que le
cap sera bientôt franchie et que le pays
pourra bientôt revenir à une certaine
forme de normalité